yes my hair character Richard you need
to prepare for the film awhile you don't
want looking up to be from a small town
there's a lot of characters people who
scared me a lot and I drew from that the
starway there's a wonderful novel by
Daniel with drell there are method
entries to watch people to observe
small-town Missouri bars to go into to
watch teardrop like people i guess i
guess i would finally say that I try to
you about in general operation apart say
what is the story and how come my
character to help tell the story so
that's actually where I jumped off and
when all that's done and the camera will
be kind of committed all of this right
here friend
over the top
the am ready
surreal i know i've been working in
relative anonymity for many years and i
like that they do you think you're
anything but what is great about this is
that it's really a wonderful for our
film and the more people will see the
movie the more that this kind of thing
happens with it makes me happy until of
the skull
the emotions of the character because
wasn't evils and also was very evil I
mean it was a scary character but also
it was very ambiguous because it was
protective of the girl yes because it
was the uncle but also in center and at
one point of using yes so can you talk
about the motion sure again I think part
of telling a story is not is not what I
would say playing the ending so turn off
isn't going to end up being someone who
gets hurt read read I it's Jennifer
Lawrence's go to kill or molester he
doesn't but I wanted it to seem like
thats always it's more tonight the
audience I believe you to watch her try
to maneuver very difficult math with
this guy is real for a lie now one thing
I think is interesting is people often
say teardrop changes in the movie I look
how we change but if he changes at all i
think you have the same guy from the
moment we met him till he goes to his
death at the end he's just protecting
his his his niece this family right here
mr. hawk you played terrifying
characters in this film are commercial
may marlene late Apple born
there isn't me you everyone we know and
instead what which is preferable and
more importantly which is more lucrative
for you as an actor well I would have to
add it up I'm not sure which would show
whether playing a mean folks or sweet
folks makes more money I don't know
which I'm always looking for the best
story and the best people in the bench
of character I can find yeah thank you
how do you feel about your Oscar chances
tomorrow given what you just said about
preferring to remain kind of anonymous
below the radar I mean every kind of
destroyed the convincing aspect of your
life window well it was a pretty clumsy
speech today not figuring with so
tomorrow if I win different people worst
person of doing that now you know I'm
already a winner the distance being
thought of alongside all those people
appreciated it is truly an honor to be
nominated something I laughed at but
when it happens to you it's true and
whatever happens I'm just really happy
that people are finding this film right
here today
I'm sorry
for me as an actor of all the David so
are the big Roberta to do in time in
prison and I having a lot of times I
think there's a game different things
like that we use a teardrop as in the
book if that's hard to character
hesitate for the 40 shows your necks
distribution of the woman it get up to
me I guess from now on a smile on my
face
Oh
yes I try to find that again the best
the best story and the best character i
can find within that story that has
people who are telling that story so it
kind of doesn't really matter if it's a
budget of ten thousand dollars or 100
million dollars if i can find a great
party hungry people had a great story I
want to hear the America learn from this
depiction of a community that probably a
lot of us on the coasts I'm ray that
familiar with I mean it really is
applied across a lot of America reserved
business problem yeah only that the
movie preachers and always do what our
company needs to learn it just puts it
out there that there are people like
this and there are rural communities who
are ravaged my methamphetamines there's
unemployment I think it's just you know
holding a mirror up to the truth for
today hopefully our art goes well thank
you thank you
Yeah right here